Adventures of Tom Sawyer.
Join Tom on a journey of action-packed adventure.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
The old lady pulled her spectacles down and looked over them about the room.
Then she put them up and looked out under them.
She seldom or never looked through them for a so small a thing as a boy.
They were her state pair, the pride of her heart, and were built for style, not service.
She could have seen them through a pair of stove lids just as well.
She looked perplexed for a moment and then said, not fiercely, but still loud enough for the furniture to hear.
And that is the first chapter of Tom Sawyer, the book by Mark Twain.
Twain gang. Did that end on, like, she said and then not finishing what she said?
I think it was like a she said, like, to end a sentence.
Oh, okay. You know.
I guess I drifted out of that for a little bit.
Yeah. I'm not sure, like, what, like, what that means either at the end, though.
Like, loud enough for the furniture to hear.
But, you know, furniture doesn't have ears.
So I guess that's like, you know, crazy book talk.
Yeah, literature is bullshit.
But really, though, what is the appeal of these games?
Is the appeal of games like this and Dr.
Jackal and Mr. Hyde supposed to, like, beat a fool parents into thinking that, like, now their kids can experience acclaimed literature, like, in a new format?
Like, do they think that they're just getting the Sparknotes video game version?
That's sort of what I'm getting the feel for.
Like, I, you know, for some reason, Tom Sawyer and Huck Finn was not a part of our syllabus in middle or high school.
So I never actually read these books.
I just, like, read about Mark Twain.
It was like, oh, yeah, he's, he did stuff.
So I really don't know what any of this is based off.
It could just be all bullshit.
And, like, he just wears a hat.
So therefore, he's Tom Sawyer.
But yeah, I guess I'm not the target demographic or ever was.
Yeah, I also never read, never read this in school or anything.
So, so, so I'm not super clear on it all either.
I didn't think it was, I didn't think just from my, my, like, general knowledge that it was like a fantastical.
Story, unless it is about his, like, imagination or whatever.
I don't know. I don't want to make myself stupid by talking about Tom Sawyer and not knowing what I'm talking about.
But, but I don't know.
I, I, I was thinking the same thing.
I was wondering, like, why would they choose, like, literary characters for their video games?
And I mean, another option could be that maybe it's just like, okay, here's a generation of people who don't know Tom Sawyer.
We don't have to create a character.
We already have some elements.
We can just, we can just do it again.
I mean, I think that works more with, like, movies.
But, like, if you think about something like, like Sherlock Holmes, like, they're still, you know, they're still making Sherlock Holmes stuff now and, like, introducing a new generation to it.
Not that I think that the Adventures of Tom Sawyer for the NES was, like, a great way to introduce a new generation to the material.
Yeah, we need, like, a dark and gritty reboot about Tom Sawyer, like, the imaginations of, like, Gen Z kids or something.
Right, right. And the Adventures of Tom Sawyer, the video game, is not really, like, the book other than you're Tom Sawyer and I guess, like, you're still, um, I forget the name of the girl.
Somebody who read the manual would remember.
Becky. Becky something.
Okay, yeah, you're going to save her.
So, like. So, that's the historic love interest of Tom Sawyer.
Well, it's Tom Sawyer and Huckleberry Finn, right?
Which, technically, you can play as Huckleberry Finn, too, if you're the second player.
I think, you know, that's a nice touch.
Yeah, I read that. I didn't do that.
But. Is Huckleberry Finn, like, an imaginary friend of Tom Sawyer?
Does anybody know? I was just hoping we wouldn't talk about the book again so I didn't have to see me ignorant anymore.
I haven't thought about the book since eighth grade and I kind of don't want to.
So, Mike, you read it.
Yeah, well, I did read it, but, you know, mostly I remember the painting the picket fences.
I don't remember fighting the giant octopus in chapter one.
Which is something that happens in the game.
Yes. You know, but this is a platforming game, again, where you play as Tom Sawyer, and if you're a player, too, you play as Huckleberry Finn.
And you travel through just six levels, but they're pretty, you know, giant in size.
And Tom Sawyer is, you know, from the cutscene that we get in the beginning of the game, he's in, like, school or something, and he's dreaming.
And in this dream, he has to save, as Sean mentioned, Becky from Injun Joe, which I think I'm allowed to say because that's the character's name.
I think you're allowed to say it.
Yeah, yeah. I know it's not the best, but this is what we got to deal with.
This is the material we've been given.
And, yeah, so you're going to travel in this platforming game through six stages to get to rescue her.
I'm not quite sure what sets Tom Sawyer apart from other platforming games.
So, Joe, Sean, is there anything specifically that you want to call out in regards to being or controlling Tom Sawyer?
I'll say that...
Yeah, go, Joe. I'll say I was pretty surprised, maybe just because of my, like, extremely low expectations for a game about The Adventures of Tom Sawyer, that it controls really nicely as a platformer on the NES.
Like, it's kind of how, before we started this whole nostalgia experiment, kind of how I expected most NES games to control.
You know, it's no Super Mario Bros., but it feels good in a way that even, like, some games that we rate really highly don't feel as good to control, for the most part.
It's not without its control, like, fluidity flaws.
But I don't know if you guys felt the same way.
I think it's got a relatively intuitive, like, physics system.
Like, obviously there's no physics system.
But when I say that, I just mean, like, does the jump feel like something that you can do?
And it's not as expressive as a Mario game.
But it at least, like, allows for some wiggle room.
Like, there is some post-jump input.
But, like, this is all very, like, nitty-gritty.
I don't think, like, the controls of this game were particularly great.
But I think that's sort of what you're saying.
It's just, like, it was passable.
Because that's really, like, all there is going on in terms of, like, the platforming levels of this game.
And you're kind of like Mario with the Fire Flower at all times, right?
Like, you have this, I guess you're throwing rocks at first.
And then you have the ability to get the slingshot.
But unlike Mario's Fire Flower, the arc of these rock throws seems to be purposefully designed to go around the enemies.
Unless you, like, hit them in the perfect spot.
There's something about the arch, you know, of the way they throw.
That the enemy sprites are either, like, small enough that they'll go over them.
Or they, like, fly in an area where it won't be able to quite hit them unless you jump in time to hit as well.
I found that to be a little interesting of a control device.
Instead of squashing enemies like how you would in Super Mario Bros.,
you're stuck with just having your rock to throw at these guys.
The enemies just sort of appear very close to you, too, on screen.
So there's not much of a warning.
You kind of have to, this is another one of those games where, and we've had these early on,
where you have to play a little cautiously if you want to live long,
just because you're not sure of the speed at which the enemies approach you once you do see them.
Yeah, the first, my first continue, and it wasn't really a continue.
I just had to restart the whole game.
Lasted maybe, like, half of the first level.
I just kept dying.
But then I just realized, like, I have to play this game at a different pace than I'm used to.
And I was able to, you know, pretty handily continue on as long as I was playing a little bit slower.
Yeah, it's not, like, an overly difficult game, but it is, like, it does surprise you sometimes with the enemies.
Like, there's a lot of enemy variety, and a lot of them do different things.
Like, even later in the game, suddenly an enemy will start doing something that you haven't seen done before.
Coming at you at a different angle or at a different speed,
or circling you in a way where you have to think about how you're going to catch them,
because, like you said, Mike, they're too close to you for you to hit them with the irregular rocks because of the arc of your throw.
Which could be seen as annoying and could also be seen as part of the game design of trying to really gauge how you're going to hit each of these enemies.
And that would be a good thing, right?
Like, if the enemies constantly change, I mean, we don't see that in every game, right?
A lot of times you're introduced to the different enemy types throughout the beginning of the game,
and then they either just get stronger or they have more health.
You know, like, either they do more damage to you or they have more health to retain more damage from you.
But in this game, the problem comes from the fact that there's a weird size to everything,
like, and a weird control to everything that you are.
Like, with Tom going up and down ladders, there's this thing where, like, you almost think you're done climbing the ladder,
but if you aren't at the very tippy-tippy top, you fall all the way back down to the beginning.
And I can't help but feel like that's the actual problem.
It's not the enemies.
It's the way you move within the space that makes everything a little extra challenging for this game.
And if there was a way to fix that, I don't know if it's, like, just making everything a little more zoomed out
so you can have more screen real estate to, you know, like, just so this way you can see yourself
and see what's coming at you from further away.
I think that's, like, what Super Mario Bros.
does, right? Like, you always see the Goombas just kind of slowly marching towards you.
They never just, like, pop up.
But there are things in Super Mario Bros.
that pop up, like, say, piranha plants out of warp pipes.
Like, so there just has to be a balance.
And this game didn't exactly figure out that balance and made it more just about
the actual traversal of the stages is the challenge rather than the types of enemies.
Yeah. Well, to sort of help kind of illustrate that, too, one thing I noticed,
if everybody's, I'm assuming, maybe not, but I'm assuming a lot of people in our audience
have played Super Mario Bros.
3. I would assume so.
And if you remember in that game, they're the Cheap Cheaps.
Or any Super Mario Bros.
games, but they're the Cheap Cheaps.
There are some levels, the Cheap Cheaps are the little fish that jump out of the water.
There are some levels where they just, when you hit a certain spot on, you know,
the platform you're on, a fish will jump out of the water in your direction at you.
And it's pretty well designed.
Something very similar, almost exactly the same idea as in this game,
a fish that jumps out of the water at you,
but it jumps out of the water literally, like, at the pixel you're already standing on
or that you're jumping towards.
And there's no avoiding it unless you, unless you, like, timidly jump a little bit forward
and then land back where you started, like, for every jump to see where it's coming from
because you don't know where they're coming from.
So it's like, it's like, yes, they had, like, that good, that good idea there,
but it was implemented in a way where it's, like, just not player friendly.
It makes it so, like, avoiding it is possible, but not fun.
It's just, like, a chore to, like, test every step.
You know, that's one little tiny part of this game, but, you know,
I think that that really is where I felt the most of what you're talking about.
Yeah, I get, so one thing about the enemies in this game is a lot of them are based on player input,
and I don't really know if it's, like, a one-to-one thing,
but even in the first level, one of the standard mobs is, like, a pirate dude,
and it will react to when you throw a rock, and it will dodge the rock,
and part of that is cool.
Like, it's cool to see that kind of dynamic response to you,
and it's not just, like, an enemy that's walking towards you single-mindedly,
but other parts of that, it's just kind of annoying because it feels cheap
because it's just reading your inputs,
and I don't know if it's good or bad,
but there were those aspects to these enemies, it seemed,
in the standard levels and even in the raft levels,
so it's kind of a mixed bag.
Yeah, I had mixed feelings about that specific enemy, too,
but the part of me that liked it just to play Devil's Advocate
was because it does make, you know,
it feels different than all the other enemies that you're running into,
and it makes, like, that enemy encounter feel like a moment every time.
You know, it makes it feel like, okay, I've got to think about how I can,
you know, he's going to jump, so I've got to jump,
or I've got to wait until he lands and be far enough away from him.
So, like, I like that element of it,
but, yeah, it is sort of, I don't know, counterintuitive at times.
And, Sean, you mentioned the raft stage,
which, you know, that's not a platforming thing.
The game almost becomes a shmup where you now throw your rocks.
Almost, yeah. Like, guns, you know?
Like, you're shooting your rocks out of a gun or something,
and you're going on this raft,
and there's something really interesting here, though,
with the level design where, as Tom Sawyer, you have this,
you know, who cares if it's unrealistic or not?
You have this very large jump that doesn't sync with the raft below you,
but you still have freedom of your jump in the air
so that even if your raft is being, like, pulled in a specific direction
or you're not quite lined up with it,
you still get a chance to do that.
To correct, yeah. And I almost wonder, like, that's a game in itself,
and it's only used for one level.
Like, it's never called back to.
There's no other additional, like, bonus modes in this game.
Why do you think they did that?
So that's one of the most interesting parts of this game
is that because, like, by all measures,
this, I don't know if we've really made it clear
with how we're talking about it so far,
but, like, a lot of this game is kind of ho-hum,
like, oh, this is just one of those 700 games in the NES.
But you can tell that they're trying things,
whether it's the enemy design or the platforming
or this sort of this raft game design.
They are trying things.
And the fact that they had it so that you are part of this,
you're riding this raft and you have to jump.
Like, there are parts that you just have to.
And it's sort of like a complex,
a relatively complex mechanic
where it's going to just continue with momentum
of however you left the raft going when you jumped
and you now have to avoid whatever obstacle
you were trying to avoid while also landing on the raft.
And that is engaging and that is cool,
but it just happened so infrequently.
It was just that one level for the most part
that you have to worry about it.
But, like, that was probably one of the most engaging
parts of the game for me was, like,
now I have to do these things at the same time.
I don't really know how to describe it beyond that,
but I like that.
Do you guys like that?
Yeah, I thought that was a great, you know,
and I thought a similar thing about some of the other levels as well,
but not to the extent of this raft level,
that it was a great, like, format change
and it was something we haven't seen before.
It made me think differently about it.
And it was pretty fun.
And, you know, I got to say,
I think that your description of it being
just another one of the 700 games on the NES
is, like, the perfect way to articulate what this game is for me.
But I will say, with things like this raft thing,
I think it blends into all, like, yeah,
that list of all those other games like that,
but it does feel, at least to me, above average
because of its ambition and, like, trying new things
and not just getting, like,
not just getting, doing the same thing over and over again,
adding, like, a raft level.
Yes, I would have liked more of those,
but having the enemy variety and all that stuff,
it was kind of cool to me.
I mean, yeah, but I do think there's a difference, though,
between, like, a game trying a lot of different things
or feeling of progression
and then also, like, making sure that those things work well.
So I feel like a lot of the things that this game introduces
either don't matter because they can be cheesed
or they become frustrating because of their design development.
Oh, absolutely. Yeah, you know, the boss fights are something that's, like...
I accidentally cheesed these boss fights.
Right, right. You don't even know you're doing it,
but, like, that octopus one we keep talking about,
it's just the first boss. There's other cool bosses, too,
like a giant water dragon and a gorilla.
But, like, the octopus, just as an example,
if you just constantly fire at it,
before it ever shoots its first attack at you,
it will die.
That thing attacks?
I didn't even know it attacks.
I thought it was, like, teaching you what boss battles are.
I didn't even know I had an attack.
But that could have been an exciting thing.
That could have been an exciting moment for the game
and a nice boss fight where you have to, like,
dodge the tentacles or something and hit the weak spots,
but it doesn't do that.
And yet there are other elements of this game
that, whether through, like, platform trickery
or through, you know, the way enemies appear on screen,
it becomes a harder game than it has to be.
It's almost like the game isn't balanced in a way
where, like, any particular level of this game
isn't challenging,
but there are challenging moments in each level
that just become confusing.
Yeah. Like, wait, why is this the hard part?
Yeah, and, like, when you say that there's a difference
between seeing interesting ideas
or new ideas and how they execute,
like, that's basically, like, that's the story of this game
is that, like, I can tell
they're trying to do something.
Something that isn't, like,
because this is a Thomas Sawyer game,
and no, it's not, like, a big franchise.
Like, they're just making a game
and trying to make parts of it unique.
So I see that, and I give them credit for that.
But, like, yeah, it's obviously,
the execution is flawed.
And I think most games
that aren't just straight cash grabs,
we can see something like that.
And it's just odd seeing it
in something that is so,
what I imagine is so, like, laser-focused
and just, like, this is just a game
we're going to try and sell to parents
as, like, an edutainment thing,
and then the game is just nonsense
about dragons and throwing rocks.
Like, it just, like,
it illustrates the history
of NES shovelware.
And I'm not saying this game is shovelware,
but it may as well be with how...
Yeah, no. Yeah. Go ahead.
I get exactly what you're saying
because it's almost like,
you know, the assignment
from the publisher was clear, right?
Like, oh, we want to take
the Tom Sawyer, like, book
and make it into a video game.
And then you just get a couple of guys
who know how to put together a game,
almost like tag team in, you know,
be like, all right, cool. You did your 30 minutes of programming.
You're in, Brian. Now it's my turn. Yeah.
Right. And you just, like,
take either the elements or whatever.
And, Joe, I'm sure you'll disagree,
but I don't mean that, like, 100%.
I just think, like, at times,
not that the game feels bipolar,
but it feels uneven
in its own difficulty.
There are times in this game,
even in later levels,
where you could just avoid everything
and keep making forward progress
and you have, you know,
you only have, like, your health as it is.
Like, there's no extra health bars
or anything to cheese it,
but you don't have to make contact with much.
And then there's other moments in this game
where all of a sudden
there's, like, eight enemies
and now you're flying on a balloon
and you have to dodge thunderclouds
that are shooting, you know,
bolts of lightning at you.
And it's just, like, when did this take over?
Like, I didn't expect this to just happen.
Well, so I don't fully disagree,
but it does seem like I have a higher opinion
on the game overall than you guys might.
But I'll say that, like, for what's...
I think part of it is because of my expectations
going into it, because of what you're talking about,
this being a Tom Sawyer game
that someone just said, like,
okay, let's just try and see
if we can get this out there.
But to me, it seems clear that, like,
almost against the odds,
somebody who developed this game
really cared about it.
Like, we've had so many games on the NES
that just kind of, like, okay, they just put it out there.
This feels like someone was, like,
oh, I really want... Like, someone had some ideas
and someone was passionate about it,
which is what surprised me the most.
Like, it feels like
they put the effort
into making the game feel good.
They put the effort into making this enemy variety.
I mean, literally every stage
has, like, totally different enemies
and totally different, like,
ways about it. Structure, yeah. And there's no stage
in particular to me
that feels bad
or just thrown in there.
I think that, you know,
the flaws that we're talking about,
like, they just come up
throughout a little bit.
And I even think some of them,
I mean, I think I have a higher opinion
on some of these things we're calling flaws
than you guys do, too,
because I didn't hate
the enemy placement
other than really that one...
The only one I could think of
is the one that I mentioned
with the fish.
Like, some of it was definitely not, like...
No, no, I don't hate
Perfect game design,
but, like...
What's that? I don't hate the enemy placement.
It was more so just, like...
No. I'm sorry.
Finish your thought. That's all right.
Placement was maybe the wrong word,
but with what you guys are talking about
where it's, like, yeah, the AI being
a little cheap sometimes
or, like, I know that there are times
where, like, an enemy just comes at you
and, like, if you didn't think
about it ahead of time,
you're kind of screwed,
which would suck
if it didn't, like...
I felt like I sort of
learned that stuff
pretty early on whenever I met a new enemy
and then when I saw them again,
I at least had the knowledge
to, like, figure out, like,
what I should have done
even if sometimes I didn't do it and died.
I could still be like, well, okay,
I guess I screwed that up
and I should have done something else.
I'm not fully in that camp either.
Like, I definitely think
that that element of this game
could have been buttoned up and improved,
but it just didn't, like...
It was nowhere near as bad
as some other games that we've had
where, like...
I think it was, like, was it the Karate Kid
or one of those games?
Yeah, Karate Kid has a lot of problems
that I think, you know,
you're right. We're saying this game
has those problems. It doesn't have that
on that scale, but it is worth highlighting
that there are some issues.
Yeah, but I don't think
that I've been criticizing
this game's enemy placement.
I think I've... I mean,
what I've been saying about this game
is that a lot of it
is cookie cutter, except for a lot of it,
but it's all...
None of it really
makes it feel
like a cohesive piece.
It's just like,
oh, it does this thing
and that's new, but it only does that
for a level. And like, oh,
these enemies, like,
respond to you in a way.
And sometimes it feels cheap,
but otherwise, it's actually like...
It's kind of an interesting way
to build some enemy behaviors,
but it's only a few of them.
And so a lot of it
is just like, oh, it did this well,
but it was just...
It's just one piece
of an otherwise,
like, un...
And I'm kind of like
telegraphing my opinion,
but yeah. You don't take what you've learned
and then have to improve it
in the next level where it throws, like,
the harder version of that
at you or anything like that.
Like, it's just like...
It's just like six
totally different things.
And like, I was going to save this
for my essential vote,
but maybe this will like
help clear up
kind of how I'm feeling about it.
Like, by the end of this,
I felt personally like
this was the first six levels
of what would have been
a pretty good game.
Like, I felt like it was like...
I wanted more of this.
I wanted like more levels
like this later.
Like, you know, like, I felt like it was just like
they had a bunch of ideas
and they just put them all in here
with no, like...
Yeah, no through line.
Yeah. That is like...
We haven't really touched upon it,
but for something
that's supposed to be based off
of a literary,
historic, like, through line
of American culture,
this makes no sense.
And I think even
if I knew Tom Sawyer,
this would make no sense.
Does it make sense?
Did anybody read this?
We didn't... Well, I mean,
I didn't read the manual,
but I'll tell you,
like, you know, just from playing the game.
No, it is a nonsensical adventure here
where they just took, you know, the idea...
First off, I don't feel like they put
any personality traits
of Tom Sawyer
into his character, right?
I mean, he just throws rocks,
but give him a paintbrush.
Give him a paintbrush
as a weapon or something.
I don't know. Isn't he like a con man
or something? Like, isn't that his thing?
What'd you say? Isn't he like a con man?
Yeah, he's a con man.
I thought Tom Sawyer
was just a little school boy
that, like, did his homework
but also had some daydreams.
He should have been able
to bribe the enemies with money.
If you have enough cash,
they won't attack you. Wow.
Okay. See? No, no, no.
What I really mean, though,
is I just want to get back to my earlier point
because I think this is
a little bit of what Sean was saying
and a little bit of what Joe was saying
is that this game
didn't need to be these six levels.
It definitely needed
to be more fleshed out,
but even if you broke up
these levels a little more
based on the design mechanics
that we experience
for mere moments of gameplay
and instead flush those out
as their own levels,
similar to what happens
with the Raft, right?
Like, if there was a whole level,
not just 15 seconds,
where you're riding a cloud,
I could get on board with that.
Yes, it's nonsensical,
but aren't most of these NES games?
I think that's a cooler idea
is just elongating your ideas
and doing it the usual Nintendo approach
where first you learn the new concept,
then you introduce the enemies,
then it gets a little harder,
then you take on a boss.
Like, if they would have done that
for each moment of these games,
rather than make these little sweet spots
in each level where something cool happens,
I think you would have gotten
a better game. Yeah, for sure.
Absolutely. So you guys hadn't looked
through the manual, right?
I skinned the back flat.
Okay, well, what I think is interesting
about this manual is, like,
it just steps you through
the entire game,
which I know, like,
okay, that sounds like a walkthrough,
but no, it steps you through, like,
it steps you through, like, this is where your journey begins.
Here are all the levels.
Here are all the enemies. These are each two levels.
Great. Here's how the game ends.
Yeah, like, oh, also there's this part,
like, the wake-up Tom part.
You know, it's like,
it just tells you exactly,
it's a text description
of, like, the final scene of the game.
Like, it's literally exactly what happens.
It's very quirky. Like, it's strange
because it puts it as a section
as if it's, like, something
that you're going to need guidance on.
It's literally just a, it's just an end screen
with a little cinematic image
of Tom doing his thing
and, like, realizing that,
was this a dream or was it not?
And it, like, tells you that
in the manual. So I just felt like
something about this manual
makes me feel like this is,
this would have been, like,
I don't know, a game designed for, like,
little kids, which is it when you play it.
This is also, Joe,
this is the moment
where I was talking about
a couple episodes ago
where, like, the manual lets you experience
the full game, something you might not do
in the game itself.
So if you're a kid
who's unfortunate enough
to not be able to get past
the sky level
or even the haunted house level,
right, you can go to the manual
and find out how it ends.
We need to, we gotta teach these kids
to get better at video games.
Well, that's another thing.
With the manual,
like, I do remember now,
it, like, describes the,
like, why you're fighting these,
not why you're fighting these bosses
because they're all,
they're all nonsensical,
but, like, it says that, like,
oh, you'll fight a giant gorilla
that's made up of
all of these other tiny monkeys
and then you see in the game
all these tiny monkeys
get together into, like,
a cheer pyramid
and then they turn into
a giant gorilla. and I'm like,
like, why do I need,
why do I need deep lore
on why this,
this gorilla exists?
Like, why can't you just
show the giant gorilla?
I will buy a giant gorilla
in the jungle.
You don't have to describe to me
that it's made up
of these tinier monkeys
that will coalesce into,
it, it doesn't make any sense,
like, it makes less sense.
It's also funny
because, like, in the game,
it's very clear that that's how
the gorilla appears.
Yeah. Like, it's just funny to me
that in the manual it has to say, like,
it'll, like, this is how it appears.
Like, I don't know,
it's just funny because, like, you don't need either of them,
though. Like, just have a gorilla
appear. But, like, you know,
it's a, it's a, in the game,
I get it. It's like a,
it's just like a fun way
that they wanted to design it.
Like, whatever. It's it.
It adds to the game's lore
regardless of what Tom Sawyer's lore is.
I just thought it was funny
of, like, the manual to say,
like, to, like,
literally describe everything
that happens in the game,
not just the hints, but, like,
here's all, you can just read the manual
and you'll, you know the whole game.
Yeah. And in the manual,
they name the giant gorilla
too, Sarudan.
And I just think, like,
in the prequel
to the Adventures of Tom Sawyer
video game, they'll give him
his explanation for why he got that name.
Good stuff about the manual,
Joe. I did not, I did not realize
how entertaining this could be.
It's a shame. It reminds me that,
you know, the complete experience
of playing these older games
is literally,
like, you have to have
the full package. Like,
you have to look
at the crazy box art
and think about what they were trying
to sell kids, right?
Because so many kids just looked at the box art
and thought that was the game.
But most of the time
the box arts don't even match up.
Then you have the manual,
which is something that you are supposed to read
before you ever even play the game,
but will probably read
after you get stuck
in a certain way. Some people like to go in blind
and then check it back.
But, like, you're doing yourself a disservice,
like I just did here,
when you don't check
all of these things out.
And, like, if you play with the sound off,
right? So you don't hear the music.
Like, yeah, the music gets annoying,
but, like, it's part of the whole design.
So even if you're only
going to play these games
nowadays for, like,
20 minutes or an hour,
right? It's like you owe it to yourself
to get fully immersed in it
for the little time
that you have it. Yeah.
That's a good point. On the sequels and spinoffs side,
I would be remiss to tell you
that The Adventures of Huckleberry Finn
is a book that is a sequel
to The Adventures of Tom Sawyer,
which is not a video game,
and I don't think it's ever been turned into a video game.
However, there is another
Tom Sawyer video game,
and I believe it's the only
other one of its kind.
It is the Famicom exclusive
Squares Tom Sawyer.
It's the company Square,
the RPG makers. Oh, my God.
But it's called
Squares Tom Sawyer.
It's not just called Tom Sawyer
developed by Square.
Nostalgia Bite, I feel like.
It might have to be.
However, the game has never been translated
into English.
Players control Tom Sawyer
and his friends as they join the party.
You know, the party being
the party of role players
such as Jim and Huck.
And they each have RPG-like stats,
but there is no
experience level-up system.
It's done just like
Final Fantasy 2,
the game that Square made
just before making
Square's Tom Sawyer,
but afterwards
they would make Final Fantasy 3.
So this element has
the Final Fantasy 2
saga style of games
where if you take damage,
you get stronger.
If you use this weapon,
you're better at this weapon.
The game features
lots of different enemies
and lots of different things
that try to more or less
stick to the story of the book
a little closer
than this game does,
but it also features
weird things like
one particular enemy
that can trigger
the reset button
on the player's controller,
bringing them back to the title screen
without saving.
What? That's some Hideo Kojima
shit right there.
Yeah, I mean, they were thinking about it
all the way back then.
In 2010,
Yu-Gi-Oh!, the site,
ranked it as the fourth most racist
video game in history.
Racist? Yes, racist.
And I will just tell you
that I saw one screenshot,
which I will never share on our Twitter.
Oh, no. But the blackface
is bad in this game.
Like, really bad.
And Square ought to be
ashamed of themselves for doing this.
But at the same time,
it's just like, why does this even exist?
You think about all the games
that are on your wish list
of Square to make, right?
And you never would think
Tom Sawyer,
an RPG on Tom Sawyer
would be one of the games.
Yeah, when you said that,
I thought this must have been
like pre-Final Fantasy Square.
But you're telling me
that they made Final Fantasy 2
with all these new systems
based on life. Let's make some
fucking Huckleberry shit.
Yeah, they were like,
oh, we got this new system
that everyone's gonna love.
Spoiler alert, that nobody really likes
that system apparently
in Final Fantasy 2. I've never played it.
But then they're like,
oh, you know, how do we get the
Tom Sawyer fans?
We gotta adapt this
for the Tom Sawyer fans.
Very, very strange.
Especially because it only came out in Japan.
So it's like, was Tom Sawyer
Here's some American culture
for only Japan.
Yeah, maybe they were
like dodging copyright laws.
Like, we were like, oh, we don't have to pay this
because we're a Japanese company
and this is American. Well, I feel like,
I mean, it's also, it's in the public.
I think it's in the...
It is. I'm pretty sure it is, too.
I mean, how do you think
I got the first chapter of this book for a reason?
Yeah, we could be sued, actually.
I didn't think about that.
The Mark Twain estate.
I read only the first paragraph
of the first chapter
for what it's worth and I cut it off mid-seam.
That's under fair use, bro.
Yeah, there you go.
So, that's really all I have, though,
for the sequels and spinoffs. I just feel like
if anybody ever wants to try
and translate Square's Tom Sawyer,
a lot of people in this world
are probably looking for it.
Itching for it.
Now that we've mentioned it.
Yeah, itching it. We are itching to do
one last thing on this show,
although that's not necessarily true
because we do have a little fun thing after this as well,
a little fun section
to start the new year.
So fun. But first, we've got to do
the little thing that we call
the Essential Games List.
Sean, we're going to go first with you.
All right. Yeah, I feel like everything
that I've set up to this point
was foreshadowing
that, again, like,
for a game that sounds like
no one should ever play this
or everyone will have forgotten
about this game by now,
like, it is pleasantly surprising
how well it plays.
Like, it's not unpolished,
but it was just not a great idea
in the first place
if they weren't going to try
and work into some story beats
of Tom Sawyer
or just have the levels.
Like, the game should have been
a different genre, I think.
If this was like an adventure game
in, like, the Goonies style
or something, it might make a bit more sense.
But it did have some ideas,
and usually when I say that,
that means that they weren't executed well.
But obviously,
this game is not essential.
It's Tom Sawyer.
All right, all right.
I'll go next.
Pretty much echoing
a lot of what Sean said,
but one thing that I would like
to throw out there as a bone to the people
who do like
The Adventures of Tom Sawyer,
the game. The super fans.
Yeah, you know,
but like, this could be considered
a game that you
did not play
during the original,
like, time of owning an NES,
and then you go back
and you're looking for, like,
another new platformer.
And like, this makes that list, right,
of a platforming game
that you might not have heard of,
and you try it out.
And like, I just don't think
you're going to have a great time with it.
That's the problem, is like, yeah,
it's offering up some new stuff
every now and again,
and it's not, like,
it's not a glitchy mess.
It's not terribly hard.
It is one of those games
that you can probably beat
if you just, like,
keep with it. So,
yeah, like,
it probably would wind up
on at least a few people's
hidden gems list.
But I think to be
an actual hidden gem,
you don't just have to find a game that you never heard of
that's, like, somewhat decent.
A hidden gem is a game that actually,
like, is surprising
because of the route
it takes that other games
did not take,
you know, or how closely it follows
other great games.
I wouldn't think
of any game
on the essential games list
that, like, also reminds me
of Adventures of Tom Sawyer.
We've referenced a few
during this episode,
but mostly to talk about
how Tom Sawyer executes those ideas
poorly in comparison.
So, I don't think it even gets,
like, hidden gem status for me.
I think it just kind of gets,
like, this video game
was made and was sold
under Adventures of Tom Sawyer
license. It's on our official
list of that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's our official list.
I'll create another section of the website
just for that.
Joe, your thoughts?
I thought that this game,
I think, first of all,
I've said it a couple times
already, but my low expectations
going in really helped color my,
you know, the positive feelings
I had about this game. I thought that it actually
played pretty well,
and I had some fun with it.
I did. To talk about what I was
saying before about the length,
I think that,
you know, the way that you guys
then addressed that,
I agree with,
that it needs to, instead of doing a bunch of,
a ton of small,
interesting new things,
focus on one for a little while.
Let that become the game
for a little bit. And I think that that's
where I was kind of going
with the idea of it
being a longer game.
Because I think you could have
taken a lot of these things
and, you know, again,
to reference like
Super Mario Bros. 3,
you have, I think it's like
the fourth level in that
is like a sky level
where you're jumping around
on things in the sky. And then a few levels later,
there's another one where it's a little harder.
And then like later on in the game,
there's more of those. And I feel like we could have
done more of that. I would have liked
a more challenging raft level
now that I got the hang of it.
And, you know, some of these other elements
that come back in come later.
I really feel like
this is like just like a sampling
of what could have been a much larger
and, you know,
game that could end up
being considered
a hidden gem. But it doesn't quite reach that.
I see the idea
that it is like
sort of a shovelware thing.
It sort of just, it sort of just falls into
like the background
of all these other games
like this we've played. And I'll say,
if you want to, if you want to find
like one of those
random platformers,
kind of like what you said,
Mike, one of those random platformers
that are just everywhere
on the NES,
this is a good choice,
I think. If you want to find something
that you've probably never played
and no one really
ever talks about. I think this is a good choice
because it was still fun
and it controlled well.
It just, it's just the whole thing
is weird.
Like, like its existence.
Like if you, if you,
if you separate it
from its, from its like connection
to Tom Sawyer,
maybe you're like,
oh, okay, like it's,
it's an interesting
little experiment. If you,
if you then start considering
that this is a Tom Sawyer game,
you're probably like,
what the, what is this?
Why is this, you know,
granted I didn't read the book.
Maybe this is exactly
what the book is like.
Maybe this is everything. Maybe,
you know, there's,
they really were really faithful to it.
But overall,
rambling a little bit,
but not essential.
I think I'll put it on my
could have been a really good game list,
but wasn't. Yeah.
That's, that's a great list
that we will also make a whole nother section
of the website for.
Add that list. Yeah.
Now you have to remember,
I'm talking about the website
because if you haven't been
paying attention, it's back,
baby. We got the website back
thanks to the patrons
over at
patreon.com
slash nostalgia.
It just contributing
even a dollar a month
will get you a little special
thank you on the thank you page,
which is the homepage
right now for the website.
So if you ever wanted your name
on the homepage of a website,
similar to what Homer,
yeah, I think Homer Simpson
did that like back
in 2000. He was the front page
of the internet or something like that
before Reddit. You could also be
the front page of the... Kim Kardashian.
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, she broke the internet.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, yeah. We're going to break
the internet though too
because the number
of support that we have
gotten is just,
you know, we really want to
thank everybody
who's supported us so far and it's never
too late to jump in too
because at the $5
a month level,
you get access to
Nostalgia Bites
and our first episode,
Nuts and Milk,
which I have to say
like that every single time.
I'm always going to laugh.
Yep, that game,
it's coming up soon
that episode so if you want to see
what Nostalgia Bites
is all about, remember it's a look
through the Famicom library
but with no Japanese
language skills required.
We're playing the Famicom games
that you can play
without knowing anything,
without having eyes.
No, that's not true.
You need eyes. You also need ears
to hear the podcast
so I just feel like full disclosure.
One thing that we're
going to do now that has nothing to do
with giving us
any kind of money or support
or tweeting nice things
at us is we're going to
take a look at 2021
in an unfamiliar way
for us. We are going to talk
about each of us
is going to give our favorite NES game
that we played in 2021
according to the show
obviously. We can't go ahead.
We can't skip. And we're also going
to talk about our favorite game
of 2021.
The ones that came
out in 2021.
So, Sean, I don't know
if it's a good or a bad idea
but I kind of want to start
with you. It's a terrible
idea, Mike. I don't know
what you think
I'm going to say. But,
no, I mean,
for the podcast,
I think that
the game that I liked
the most was,
it's a pretty common answer
I would say, is like Ninja Gaiden.
that was
just a game
that we all really appreciated
and it was
put together
well and we had
a lot of fun with it.
I don't really have much to say
that wasn't said in the episode.
But that's my
answer for that.
But the more interesting answer
since we don't really talk about
this on the
podcast is,
you know, my favorite game
that was released in 2021.
2021. And I actually
had to go back and look
because I'm
really bad with dates
and like time scales
all messed up.
So, I looked back
and I saw what was released
recently and it's a game
that I actually played pretty
recently and it's a
game called Forgotten City.
This game
started out as I think
like a Skyrim
mod that was like
a total conversion
and like
there was no Skyrim elements.
It was just like
you play this mod
and then eventually
I think that they got
some kind of funding
and they made
their own game out of it.
I think in a different engine
but basically
I'll give a
little synopsis.
You play a modern person
that goes back
in time to like
ancient Rome
and you
enter this city
that
they all
have to follow these
rules and
not commit a
sin or else
everybody dies
and it
turns into
this Groundhog Day
slash Sherlock Holmes
slash murder mystery
thing where you're
trying to figure out
the secret of this
little town
while also
fixing your
past mistakes
and I just
really like the
narrative
structure of this
game and the
writing and the
art and all
that it's a lot
of fun so if
you're into that weird
shit I'd give
the Forgotten City a try.
That was a very nice
synopsis thank you for
that Sean and what an interesting pick
too I honestly have
not heard anything about
that so I'm
going to look into that for
sure please
and you know
we'll put a link to it in
the show notes absolutely
Joe I'll save
you a minute I'm gonna go
first just because it seems to be
that the order of things that we're
doing lately Sean, me, Joe
so real fast
my favorite NES
game of 2021
that we played was Mega Man 2
and that's a surprising answer
for me I know it's not
a surprising answer for NES fans
or anything like that because it's
one of the most popular NES games
but I was really
surprised at the
the step up
from Mega Man 1
that Mega Man 2
was it wasn't
just like you know
more creative enemies
or a longer game
which both of those
things it has but it also
figured out
like some of the more
difficult points
that Mega Man 1
was doing and found a way
to introduce
elements to make the game
not easier
right because there is an
easier mode in there
but it's just health is more
frequently given out and the
new power ups
that they give you in terms
of movement also help you
navigate the platforming sections
a little more uniquely and I
know we said this all in the
episode as well
so I don't want to go too much
further into it but I was
personally surprised because Mega Man 1
was definitely an essential game
and Mega Man 2
is a better
essential game so that says a lot
about that particular game
now my favorite
game of 2021 I have to be honest
I play a lot of
retro games
and retro games
can mean whatever you want them to mean for me
it just means like 10 years prior
so anything like 2011
and backwards
but like
that's how retro
games work if you think about it right
like anything that came out
on the Wii
is now retro
well hold on
I thought we were
talking about games that came
out in 2021
exactly so that's what
I'm saying I play a lot
of these older games
I don't play too many
2021 games
but when I do
play a game
in 2021 I often find
myself to be pretty frustrated
because I'm
used to these shorter
more quality
because I've been given
the time to like
let critic
responses set in
and the narrative
you know the canon be set
I very rarely
play bad
games unless they're
for nostalgia
you know I mostly
just play what
what is considered
like you know the greatest games of all
time and stuff like that
so for 2021 I did play
a few good games
and the one that I want to highlight
is Metroid Dread
and obviously
that's a safe
pick because
it was even nominated for
game of the year and stuff
like that but what makes
Metroid Dread interesting for me
is it is not
the highest point
in the Metroid series
even for the
2D style
games obviously
like Super Metroid
and Metroid Fusion are like
the top when it comes
to that kind of style of
game but Metroid
Dread reintroduced
that feeling to me
in a way I didn't think
anybody other than
Nintendo could this was
a Mercury Steam game
and it was
surprising how close
they got to the
quality of a game
like Super Metroid one of the
greatest games of all
time so I
would say if you're
at all on the fence about
picking up Metroid Dread
because you saw like that
it's a little more survival horror-y
or it's
a little more like straightforward
that you can't
really skip
sequences and stuff
like that first off
neither one of those things is true
so that should
help inform your opinion
but also at the end of
the day it's just a great
Metroid game
that doesn't
rely too much on
new unfamiliar
mechanics but just
relies on the best
things that Metroid is
so that's why I
had a really good time with
it because it goes
back to that idea that I
mostly just play I'm going
to go in the reverse order
just because there's
an interesting situation
for my 2021
pick in that
when I look through
all the games that
were released in 2021
or all the games that
I played in 2021
none of them were
released in 2021
I didn't play any game that
was released in 2021
did not realize that
until tonight
but
yeah so I
had to kind of go back
a little further it's a
little cheating I went
back to my most recent
game before 2021
which
was I think
in November of 2020
which was Spider-Man
Miles Morales which might
feel kind of like cheating
because just any
game that I played
the most recently to 2021
would have
to fit
that category
but rest assured
that I do
love that game
it probably is my favorite
game of 2020
so
I had
a blast with that I love
that and the
original
2018 Spider-Man
PS4 I think
that they really make you feel
like Spider-Man
they just
let you I don't
know really explore the city
which I haven't
been to Manhattan
since the
pandemic so it was
really interesting for me to
explore as
Spider-Man where I used
to be every day you're just
getting that no way home
money right now
exactly yes
I might have to
re-pick up this game
now after
seeing Spider-Man
No Way Home I'm in the Spider-Man
spirit so
I loved
that game as far
as favorite game
that we played in 2021
for the podcast
I know no one
will be surprised by this
and I promise I'm not
just trolling like I
normally do but it is
Zelda 2
which made it
in just under the
wire getting early
on in 2021
and I
just can't emphasize
enough how much
fun I had with that game
and how surprised
I was because of the
bad reputation it
has but
that game
felt like one
of the closest to
me to being
like a modern
experience I mean
obviously you could tell
it's still
an NES game
but it felt like I
was sitting down to
start this whole campaign
of a
story like
I do today that
you rarely find
on the NES and
it gave me similar
but
refreshingly
different vibes to
the original Legend of Zelda
which obviously
is way up
there as well
so
I just
can't get over how much
I love that game and
how it
is not on the essential games
list I will
definitely bring it up
in our best of best
of 1989 I'll
do my best to
try and convince you
guys otherwise I don't
know if I
can convince you guys to play
it again or whatever but
I really
want to try and get that on
all right and of
course there's lots to look
forward to in 2022
now that we're in
it there's
many games coming out
in 2022 that I know
people are excited about but
there's also 51
more episodes
of NostalgiaCast
happening in 2022
and that's something to be
thankful for in
fact there's
a lot more episodes of
NostalgiaCast to come
if you think about Nostalgia
Bites you know
just throwing! ! NostalgiaCast
NostalgiaCast Thank you.